sie verbrennen die flagge nicht weil sie
amerika hassen sondern weil sie glauben
dass amerika unter beschuss ist seine
offenheit seine freiheit seine werte
unser zdf team ist mittendrin im
tränengas dass einige demonstranten mit
laubbläsern wieder zurück pusten auf die
sicherheitskräfte
robert evans dokumentiert für die
investigativ plattform berlin kennt fast
jeden abend die abläufe über wochen
waren die proteste friedlich seit anfang
juli eskalieren sie wieder massiv ins
gibt die schuld den bundesbeamten die
donald trump ihr her geschickt hat je
brutaler sie vorgingen desto
gewalttätiger würden einige der
demonstranten
das einzige was ein autokrat versteht
ist bucht also wenn diese proteste eine
wirkung haben sollen dann müssen sie
wucht anwenden gegen den staat
das bedeutet nicht gewalt gegen menschen
jedenfalls nicht gewalt die sie wirklich
verletzt aber sie müssen versuchen die
fähigkeit des staates zu beschädigen
ihnen zu schaden
es falle ihm schwer meint evans objektiv
zu bleiben wenn anonyme
sicherheitskräfte demonstranten einfach
von der straße mitnehmen illegal sofern
kein tatverdacht vorliegen und sie
reizgas blendgranaten gummigeschosse auf
männer frauen und kinder abfeuern wenn
sie einem 26 jährigen der nicht
gewalttätig protestierte in den kopf
schießen
harris der einst aus dem irak berichtete
zeigt uns eine schutzausrüstung helm
atemschutz verbandpäckchen für
schutzhunde bei der demo marschiert ein
schwarzer block an der spitze sie sind
nur eine kleine gruppe unter tausenden
die friedlich gegen rassismus und
polizeigewalt protestieren
aber das brutale vorgehen der behörden
senkt die schwelle zur über überall in
den usa wird radikalität die neue
normalität egal ob links oder rechts
jeder ist radikaler in diesem jahr so
ist es eben
die schießen auf kleine kinder hier sind
kinder und mütter deshalb bin ich dabei
was muss passieren bürgerkrieg die haben
das provoziert deshalb lassen sie
gewalttätige demonstranten in ihrer
mitte
und so entstehen allabendlich genau jene
bilder die donald trump im wahlkampf
gerade recht kommen weil sie angst
machen weil er sich als hüter von recht
und ordnung präsentieren kann
deshalb will er das modell portland
jetzt auf andere städte ausweichen
die städte mit den problemen werden
unglücklicherweise alle von demokraten
regiert radikalen linken demokraten wie
in chicago und vielen anderen städten so
ist es halt das sind die fakten
dabei schien donald trump im juni
reichlich angeschlagen völlig
überfordert von gesundheits wirtschafts
und rassismus krisen trotz großspuriger
ankündigungen vermochte er nicht einmal
mehr eine halle zu füllen
aber ein angezählter präsident ist
längst nicht am ende sondern gefährlich
meinte eine psychologin die gemeinsam
mit dutzenden kollegen vor donald trump
war er kann keine kundgebungen abhalten
und seine anhänger einschwören auf seine
wahnvorstellungen und falschen
überzeugung
er wird andere dinge ausprobieren
ablenkungen eine der möglichkeiten wäre
einen bürgerkrieg zu entfesseln
ein bürgerkrieg zu wahlkampfzwecken
angeblich wollen seine berater nur gegen
bilder erschaffen zu einem präsidenten
ein gilt im weißen haus statt gegen
korona anzukämpfen mit einer nationalen
strategie führt tram lieber ängste vor
randalierern und einem angeblich
drohenden sozialismus
gleichzeitig machen die tramps werbung
für wohnen und andere erzeugnisse eines
lebensmittelherstellers dessen produkte
boykottiert werden bei der firmenchef
ein fan des präsidenten ist trump
verwandelt auch den garten des weißen
hauses in seine wahlkampfbühne themen
nahe am wähler mögen sie einem noch so
lächerlich vorkommen zb sein angriff auf
umweltschutz vorgaben die seien schuld
dass waschmaschinen toiletten und
duschen zu viel wasser sparen durch
köpfe zb sie wollen duschen es kommt
kann was heraus was wollen sie da machen
länger da stehen länger duschen meine
haare müssen schließlich perfekt
aussehen trumps prioritäten mitten in
der krise
das zeigt seine unfähigkeit sich der
wirklichkeit zu stellen und seinen drang
sie zu leugnen aufgrund seines
pathologischen märz ismus und seine
unfähigkeit mitgefühl zu zeigen
jetzt reicht's findet linda besser sie
es keine linke sondern republikanerin
aus einer tief konservativen familie
ich musste mich nie schämen als
amerikanerin oder republikanerin aber
jetzt ist es beschämend republikanerin
zu sein
trump ist rachsüchtig er ist
selbstverliebt er gibt vor ein christ zu
sein
das regt mich als christin auf ich habe
einfach genug wir brauchen nicht vier
weitere jahres chaos deshalb hat linda
den virgin erlebt einen antritt trump
wahlkampfspot aufgenommen sowie dutzende
anderer republikaner an der basis die
ihre partei vor trump retten wollen
indem sie erstmals demokratisch deine
meinung zu ändern ist okay so die
republikanischen wähler gegen trump auch
linda wird für joe biden stimmen er hat
bewiesen dass er überparteilich arbeitet
er hat moral er ist ein gläubiger christ
ein mitfühlender mensch er wird von
unseren verbündeten respektiert er ist
einer mit dem wir zusammenarbeiten
können
wahrscheinlich werde ich mich dafür
einsetzen dass beide nur eine amtszeit
hat wenn er gewählt wird aber jetzt
haben die eine klage im weißen haus und
ich werde dazu beitragen die aus dem amt
zu vertreiben
ein präsident den selbst eigene
parteifreunde für überfordert nach den
meinungsumfragen verliert trump derzeit
massiv stimmen in seiner
kernwählerschaft weiße ohne
hochschulabschluss weiße frauen alte
menschen sogar soldaten er selbst aber
hält sich weiter für unverzichtbar und
klüger als alle anderen
in interviews trat er habe bei einem
test mit dem die denkfähigkeit gemessen
werde
perfekt abgeschnitten besser als jeder
andere obwohl die fragen doch so schwer
gewesen sei die ersten fragen sind
einfach ich wette sie könnten die
letzten fünf nicht mal beantworten die
sind sehr schwer
das lässt sich herausfinden
also haben wir den erfinder des monates
kontaktiert den tramp absolviert doktor
nasreddine lässt mich erst mal die hände
falten damit ich nichts auf schreiben
also schummeln kann dann geht es los
[Musik]
eine uhr aufmalen und noch so einiges
mehr
aber am ende darf ich nicht trotz
zugegeben fast perfekten abschneidens
nicht als ziemliches genie fühlen mit
dem test können wir hinweise auf eine
mögliche erkrankung erkennen nicht ob
jemand ein hirn athlet ist oder super
denkt kräfte hat es ist kein iq test
kein test um zu beurteilen wie gut
jemand ist also aus dem test können sie
nicht schließen ob jemand an janine jini
können wir damit nicht finden
man muss auch kein genie sein um zu
erkennen dass bei den protesten import
nennt gewalttäter eine kleine minderheit
sind tagsüber gleich das ganze eher
einem fest aber mit einem sehr ernsten
hintergrund menschen aller hautfarben
berufe und sozialer schichten wenden
sich gemeinsam gegen systemischen
rassismus und polizeigewalt in den usa
es werden auch immer mehr der friedliche
protest soll die randale einiger weniger
überlagern
deshalb sind auch sie in portland sie
nennen sich die wall of mars die mauer
der mutter gekommen weil es um ihre
kinder und enkel gehe
demetrios 46 zweifache mutter aus
memphis der stadt in der einst martin
luther king ermordet wurde
die mütter wollen sich auch diesmal
wieder den sicherheitskräften entgegen
stellen die aus ihrer sicht
verfassungsbruch begehen im auftrag der
jobs er schickt kriegs drucken und
prallt noch damit das ist schrecklich es
ist als wollten sie die zeit
zurückdrehen und sie haben den schlüssel
dafür das ist verrückt schrecklich sich
vorzustellen dass wir weiter in einer
welt aufwachen die einen grundlos hast
eine erfahrung die jennifer christiansen
zum ersten mal gemacht hat als weiße
hatte sie diesen hass nie erlebt aber
weil die mutter von zwei kindern zwölf
und 14 jahre alt mit der wall of mars
protestierte wurde sie von männern in
kampfanzügen mit reizgas besprüht
schlagstöcke trafen ihren namen sie
wurde festgenommen
ohne angabe von gründen rechtswidrig
jennifer ist anwältin nicht was die
demonstranten sagen oder tun
rechtfertigt den einsatz von waffen die
sogar in kriegsgebieten verboten sind
das ist keine eskalation das ist
einschüchterung willkürlicher
terrorismus der autoritarismus ist da
meine familie hat italien drei monate
nachdem mussolini an die macht kam
verlassen mein großvater sei es konnten
und sagte nein danke und genau das sehe
ich hier eine harte these aber viele
sehen wie jennifer amerikas demokratie
in gefahr des starts sogar das
republikanische establishment warnt vor
einem faschistischen geschlossen so will
das lincoln projekt ein zusammenschluss
prominente republikaner die wiederwahl
trumps verhindern um ihre partei und die
freiheit zu retten dies helmut storz
dieser präsident ich kann auf
verschiedenste weise die wahl verhindern
sie verschieben indem er den notstand
ausruft und das land mit kriegsrecht
übernimmt es gibt keine begrenzung für
das was ihr tun könnte tatsächlich
verweigert donald trump im winter nur
eine antwort auf die frage ob er das
wahlergebnis anerkennen würde
ich muss mal sehen sie ich werde nicht
einfach ja sagen genauso wenig wie
letztes mal das ist meine größte sorge
dass dieser präsident die wahl stehen
erinnerungen werden wach an die wahl im
jahr 2000 damals gab es streit um die
stimmen in florida sie mussten von hand
neu ausgezählt werden während die
anwälte von george bush und al gore vor
gericht so am ende entschied der oberste
gerichtshof zu gunsten des republikaners
professor peters und heldt eine
verfassungskrise für absolut möglich
wir treffen uns an dem ort an dem im
jahr 1876 eine wahlkommission den
republikaner rutherford hayes zum sieger
über den demokraten sam tilgen erklärte
obwohl dieser eigentlich gewählt wurde
nur so wurde ein neuer bürgerkrieg
verhindert 1876 erklärten sich beide
seiten zum sieger keiner wollte
nachgeben
also selbst bei einem erdrutschsieg für
beiden in 2020 gibt es die möglichkeit
dass dieser präsident sein amt nicht
schnell und leise verlassen wird zwei
jahre zuvor 1874 hatte sich im capitol
von texas der gouverneur edmond davis
verbarrikadiert obwohl er die wahl gegen
richard koo krachend verloren hatte erst
tage nach der amtseinführung cox gab der
iss auf
bei einer ähnlichen situation beiden
eingeschworen trump verbarrikadiert
würde beiden sich jede macht als neuer
präsident nutzen damit die barrikade
beseitigt und die person drinnen
herausgeholt würde jedenfalls wenn es
nach dem gesetz aber für jemanden der
sich angeblich so einsetzt für recht und
ordnung hält trump wenig von recht und
ordnung wenn es um ihn gelacht was wenn
trump seine bewaffneten anhänger zu
hilfe ruft in louisville kentucky
demonstrierte eine miliz ihre
einsatzbereitschaft angeblich zur
verteidigung der verfassen
an ihr vorbei marschierten bewaffnete
mitglieder der black panther bewegung
die angeblich auch die verfassung
verteidigen will
beide seiten könnten einen bürgerkrieg
zu entfesseln sowohl trump fans als auch
trump gegner davon ist professor parker
überzeugt also wenn die wahl nur
ansatzweise fair verläuft hat tram keine
chance zu gewinnen aber mit all diesen
faktoren
wer weiß was da passieren wird wenn er
das irgendwie hinkriegt dann wird es eng
und wir sind auf der kante zu einem
neuen bürgerkrieg wenn dieser kerl
gewinnt
aber trump so professor parker sorge mit
seiner art selbst dafür dass sich mehr
wähler von ihm abwenden und dass es
endlich eine chance gebe das land zum
besseren zu verändern
[Musik]
trump ist gut fürs land weil er all das
schlechte an die oberfläche bringt
rassismus sexismus nati wyss muss und
jetzt können die vereinigten staaten
nicht mehr leugnen dass sie im kern
rassistisch sexistisch schwulenfeindlich
fremdenfeindlich sind besonders mit
einem tram thema mitten in die
angespannte stimmung im land gießen der
justizminister und seine parteifreunde
noch öl ins feuer
bei einer anhörung vor dem kongress
spielen die republikaner ein video mit
szenen von gewaltsamen protesten ein
dazu einen zusammenschnitt von
journalisten und politikern die von
friedlichen demonstranten sprechen was
ich nach zehn portland abspielt kann man
nicht als protest bezeichnen es ist ein
angriff auf die regierung der
vereinigten staaten
es sind amerikanische soldaten die das
anders sehen
genauer gesagt veteranen sie stellen
sich schützend vor die mauer der mütter
sie wollen die bundesbeamten hinter den
zäunen daran erinnern dass sie einen eid
geschworen haben die verfassung das
recht auf meinungs- und
versammlungsfreiheit zu verteidigen die
ex soldaten wollen künftig gemeinsam mit
den mars um dimitri demonstrieren weil
sie sich einig sein
im gemeinsamen kampf
falls märz ist der anführer der wall of
death
sie und die mütter lehnen jede gewalt ab
trotzdem hat donald trump alle
demonstranten in portland pauschal als
geistesgestörte anarchisten bezeichnet
trump beute eine mauer als er gas gegen
die kinder und die demonstranten hier
einsetzen ließ kamen die mütter als er
gas gegen sie einsetzte kamen die väter
dann die veteranen die sanitäter dann
die ärzte und krankenschwestern trump
wollte eine mauer schickte seine bundes
truppen jetzt hat der fünf mauern mütter
väter veteranen lehrer pfleger und all
die anderen hier spät abends beginnt der
schwarze block wieder mit seinen
provokationen feuerwerkskörper fliegen
sie spielen den interessen des
präsidenten damit direkt in die im etat
checkt ob ihre morgens okay sind sie
sind ein stück zurückgewichen aber
einschüchtern lassen sie sich nicht weil
amerikas werte unter beschuss sind ob
diese bilder trump helfen oder ihm
schaden entscheidet sich nicht hier
sondern erst bei der wahl
[Musik]